stockholm eux veut devenir la première
ville carbo positive au monde d'ici 2040
la capitale suédoise a déjà remporté le
titre mondial de ville la plus
intelligente et multiplie les
initiatives pour que d'ici 20 ans elle
absorbe plus de gaz polluants quel nom
et mais ça passe par les transports avec
les voitures électriques le vélopartage
l'intelligence artificielle pour les
transports en commun la chaleur produite
par les usa des centres de données et
tous est récupéré et permet de chauffer
30 mais l'appartement et systèmes de
collecte des déchets et futuriste ici
pas déboires les tubes à haute pression
enfouis dans le sol propulse des déchets
vers un centre où ils sont triés
composter recyclés et même transformé en
biocarburants le système envoie aussi un
texto aux utilisateurs pour les
sensibiliser quant aux volumes et aux
poids de leurs déchets
[Musique]